les acteurs de sports d'hiver préoccupé
donc par les marchés financiers inquiets
également avant ce regain épidémique
avec
alors outre la recrudescence donc les
cadets le vario mikron fait peur aux
places boursières les dernières
nouvelles plutôt rassurantes sur le
virus ont entraîné un net rebond des
bourses mais pour combien de temps et
surtout qu'en est il des dommages pour
l'économie réelle à l'heure où l'europe
entière fait face à une résurgence du
comider où les restrictions se
multiplient est ce qu'on doit
s'inquiéter pour 2022 pal place tout de
suite à l'édito de jacques sapir
[Musique]
jack la reprise de la pandémie qu'on
constate aujourd'hui en europe en europe
est ce qu'elle est de nature à
compromettre la croissance
oui bonjour grégory est ce qu'elle est
de nature à compromettre la croissance
s'est alors oui c'est une éventualité
qu'il faut avoir effectivement à
l'esprit parce que on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui elle a une nouvelle via
ce qu'on appelle la cinquième vague que
cette cinquième vague elle commence à
toucher toute une série de pays il ya
des pays qui ont repris des mesures de
confinement ou de quasi confinement par
exemple des couvre feux et ça peut
effectivement avoir un impact plus ou
moins important sur la croissance
jacques on enchaîne avec la reprise de
la pandémie qu'on constate aujourd'hui
en europe donc par rapport à faire
compromettre tout cela tout à fait et on
voit bien d'ailleurs que cette cinquième
vague elle a commencé plus tôt dans des
pays qui ne sont pas beaucoup vacciner
assez les pays de l'europe de l'est la
bulgarie la roumanie de là elle a
progressé vers l'ouest elle a touché
l'autriche qui d'ailleurs le premier à
un pays à avoir re confiné elle touche
l'allemagne puis les pays-bas le
danemark et maintenant elle allait elle
touche la france donc oui on voit bien
justement cette espèce de mouvement de
la pandémie et en même temps il faut
quand même dire que cette pandémie
n'apparaît pas aussi
désastreuse que les premières parce que
vous voyez on a là sur le graphique le
chiffre des contaminations je dis bien
des contaminations et effectivement les
contaminations sont actuellement plus
importante que ce qu'elle était pendant
toute l'année 2000 21 et même pendant
l'année 2020 mais le nombre de gens qui
sont en hospitalisation et encore plus
en réanimation reste toujours beaucoup
plus faible et concrètement comment
est-ce que ça soit lens sur l'europe
alors les conséquences si vous voulez
ils sont très liés aux mesures de
confinement ou de quasi confinement
comme les couvre-feux et on sait que
chaque fois qu'il ya un confinement ou
un ou un néo confinement eh bien ça
impacte à la fois les ménages qui
consomment beaucoup moins et ça impacte
aussi très nettement les entreprises et
le problème qui va se passer avec cette
cinquième vague c'est que on a déjà ce
phénomène mais on a en plus le fait que
la consommation des ménages n'est pas
revenu à son niveau de la fin de 2019
fois sombre au niveau globalement de
2019 elle a chuté brutalement en 2020
bien sûr qu'elle est repartie en 2021
mais elle tend à se stabiliser
actuellement plutôt au niveau de 2014
2015 et on le voit d'ailleurs sur le
graphique qui apparaît à l'écran et donc
ça c'est un sujet de préoccupation pour
tous les économies parce que tout le
monde comprend que quand il ya moins de
consommation ya moins d'activités
économiques et comment ça s'explique
concrètement alors l'une des
explications c'est très certainement
l'importance de l'épargné accumulée
alors vous savez que l'épargné accumulée
là on voit aussi le graphique
au niveau de la zone euro bon elle a été
spectaculaire en 2020 alors pour la zone
euro c'est pour l'ensemble des pays on
est passés grosso modo de 14 % de taux
départ à 21 % du pipe de taux dépargne
en france et bien on a vu que pendant
les confinements c'était 165 milliards
d'euros qui avait été épargnée ce plomb
c'est peut-être un petit peu moins c'est
que en même temps il y avait 30 % des
ménages qui n'avait pas épargné qu'il y
avait des épargnes et c'est la pression
de la pauvreté et que cette épargne elle
est très concentré sur les 10 % les plus
riches sur le dernier décile qui à lui
seul en a fait 130 milliards alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que les gens qui ont surtout énormément
épargnée ne sont pas nécessairement très
pressé de réinvestir cet argent en dit
long de leurs dépenses et et on voit
très bien ils ne peuvent pas le dépenser
actuellement les voyages à l'étranger
sont quand même très restreint
il ya toute une série d'activités qui
commence à être restreinte si ce n'est
dans la loi du moins dans les faits par
exemple il ya beaucoup de restaurateurs
ou de gens qui organisent des événements
qui annonce des chutes de chiffre
d'affaires de 20 à 30% par rapport à ce
qu'il comptait faire pour noël donc il y
à bien aujourd'hui une forme de
contraction générale de la consommation
et de ce fait on va avoir une épargne
accumulée qui ne sert pas à grand chose
donc on a raison d'être inquiets pour la
croissance alors bien pour 2021 je ne
pense pas que ça aura beaucoup d'impact
un très sérieusement je pense que pour
2021 bon on fera peut-être pas les 6 7%
qui ont été prévu par l'insee mais on ne
devrait pas aller au delà d'un recul de
0 5% donc de passer à 1 6 0 2% pour 2022
c'est un autre problème parce que même
si la france ne connaît pas de nouveaux
reconfirme ans et il ya toute une série
de raisons d'abord le fait qu'
évidemment avec le vaccin peut être
qu'on en aurait pas besoin et puis il ya
quand même une raison majeure
c'est le fait que nous allons avoir des
élections en 2022 donc même si la france
ne connaît pas de nouveau confinement et
bien si les confinements continuent de
se multiplier dans des pays voisins
autrement dit si l'activité des pays
voisins commencent à chuter de manière
importante par rapport à ses confidents
est d'ores et déjà on assiste à une
chute de la production industrielle qui
est non négligeable en allemagne et ce
qui est encore plus important c'est une
chute de la demande alors elle est pour
l'instant plutôt moins forte dans les
pays de l'union européenne et la chute
la plus importante c'est au niveau de la
non union européenne autrement dit du
reste du monde néanmoins ça veut dire
que il y à bien d'autres mécanismes qui
sont aussi en oeuvre et oui
effectivement on peut avoir quelques
inquiétudes sur le taux de croissance
que l'on connaîtra en 2022 merci jacques
saint-pierre pour votre édito économique
et la semaine prochaine ce sera votre
100e et dit tout à fait écho tout à fait